PARTNER, AS IT DEFENDS ITSELF
AND ITS FREEDOM.
WILL RIPLEY IS "OUT FRONT" IN
TAIPEI.
>> Reporter: A RESOUNDING SHOW
OF AMERICAN SUPPORT FOR TAIWAN
IN THE FACE OF ESCALATING
THREATS FROM CHINA.
U.S. HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
LANDING IN TAIWAN.
MINUTES AFTER PELOSI'S ARRIVAL,
CHINA ANNOUNCED A SERIES OF
TARGETED MILITARY OPERATIONS IN
RESPONSE TO THE HOUSE SPEAKER'S
VISIT.
STATE KBLEED PUBLISHING A MAP OF
THE DRILLS WHICH BEGAN DURING
THE OVERNIGHT HOURS.
SOME JUST MILES FROM THE
TAIWANESE COAST.
AS PELOSI'S CONVOY ARRIVED, A
HEAVY POLICE PRESENCE.
TWO GROUPS OF PROTESTORS
GATHERED OUTSIDE.
SOME WELCOMED PELOSI'S SUPPORT
FOR TAIWAN.
>> THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
NANCY PELOSI, HAS BEEN
SUPPORTING TAIWAN FOR DECADES,
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR ME
AS A TAIWANESE TO BE HERE
TONIGHT TO WELCOME HER.
>> Reporter: OTHERS ACCUSE HER
OF ESCALATING TENSIONS.
>> Translator: RIGHT NOW PELOSI
AND THE UNITED STATES ARE
TREATING TAIWAN AS A CHESS
PIECE.
ONCE SHE LANDS IN TAIWAN,
MAINLAND CHINA WILL RETALIATE
USING THEIR OWN METHODS.
>> Reporter: CHINA'S FOREIGN
MINISTRY CALLING PELOSI'S STOP
IN TAIWAN A SEVERE IMPACT ON THE
ONE CHINA PRINCIPLE.
TAIWAN SAYS CYBER ATTACK KNOCKED
SOME GOVERNMENT WEBSITES
OFFLINE.
NO IMMEDIATE CLAIMS OF
RESPONSIBILITY.
BEIJING CALLS TAIWAN A BREAK
AWAY PROVINCE.
THE MAINLAND RULERS HAVE NEVER
CONTROLLED THE ISLAND OF ALMOST
24 MILLION PEOPLE.
THEY REFUSE TO RECOGNIZE FAYE
JUAN'S DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED
GOVERNMENT.
THERE IS AN ONGOING CAMPAIGN OF
BULLYING BY BEIJING USING THE
ECONOMIC POWER TO ISOLATE THE
ISLAND.
IN A WASHINGTON POST OP ED
PELOSI WRITES, IN THE FACE OF
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY'S
ACCELERATING AGGRESSION, OUR
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION'S VISIT
SHOULD BE SEEN AS AN UNEQUIVOCAL
STATEMENT THAT AMERICA STANDS
WITH TAIWAN, OUR DEMOCRATIC
PARTNER, AS IT DEFENDS ITSELF
AND ITS FREEDOM.
THAT SENTIMENT ECHOED BY OTHERS.
>> FOR CHINA TO TURN WHAT IS IN
THE HISTORICAL NORM INTO AID
CRISIS OR TO TRY TO USE IT AS A
PRETEXTS FOR AGGRESSIVE ACTION
AROUND TAIWAN, THAT'S ON THEM.
AND THEY WOULD BE THE ONES WHO
WOULD BE ESCALATING.
>> AND WILL IS IN TAIPEI.
OBVIOUSLY, WILL, WHERE YOU ARE,
YOU'RE AHEAD HERE.
SO IT'S 7:00 IN THE MORNING.
SPEAKER PELOSI IS THERE AND
ABOUT TO START HER DAY.
SO WHAT DO WE EXPECT TO SEE IN
TAIPEI?
I MEAN, EXACTLY HOW IS THIS
GOING TO BE CORE RIO GRAPHED?
IN THESE NEXT HOURS, WHAT COULD
CHINA DO?
>> YEAH.
WELL, WE KNOW THAT THESE CHINESE
MILITARY DRILLS ARE HAPPENING
OFF THE CHINESE COAST.
THEY STARTED OVERNIGHT.
NOT JUST STATE MEDIA, BUT THE
DEFENSE MINISTRY, PEOPLE'S
LIBERATION ARMY ANNOUNCED THESE
ARE HAPPENING AND THEY PUT OUT A
MAP SHOWING SOME OF THEM ARE
COMING LITERALLY WITHIN MILES OF
THE CHINESE COAST.
IF THEY'RE LOUD ENOUGH, PEOPLE
IN TAIWAN ON THE SHORELINE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO HEAR CHINA CONDUCTING
MILITARY EXERCISES AROUND THE
ENTIRE ISLAND.
FROM SPEAKER PELOSI'S
PERSPECTIVE, WE EXPECT TO SEE
THEM GO ON THROUGH THE DAY AS
PLANNED.
SO WE NOW HAVE CONFIRMED THAT AT
10:30 LOCAL TIME, 10:30 EASTERN
SHE'LL BE MEETING WITH THE
CHINESE PRESIDENT AND THEY'LL
TALK ABOUT THEIR SYSTEM HERE.
SHE'S BEEN A REAL CHAMPION FOR
DEMOCRACY HERE, ERIN.
IT'S VERY YOUNG.
SEVERAL DECADES.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE RUNNING THE
COUNTRY, A LOT OF THEM WERE
MEETING ILLEGALLY IN BASEMENTS
AND EVEN SERVED TIME IN JAIL AND
NOW THEY'RE RUNNING THE COUNTRY.
THAT IS HOW FRESH AND YOUNG
TAIWAN'S GOVERNMENT IS.
PELOSI MADE IT WITH HER
STATEMENT VERY CLEAR, SHE WANTS
TO PROTECT THAT.
CHINA NEVER RECOGNIZED THE
GOVERNMENT HERE AND THEY SAY
THEY'LL TAKE THE PLACE BACK.
THESE MILITARY EXERCISES AN
ATTEMPT TO INTIMIDATE AND SEND A
MESSAGE CH WHEN CHINA IS READY,
THEY WILL BE A PART OF THE
COUNTRY.
>> IT'S 7:07 HERE.
THE SPEAKER WILL BE COMING OUT
OF HER HOTEL, MEETING WITH
MEMBERS OF PARLIAMENT AND BY
10:30 EASTERN TIME, 10:30 IN
TAIPEI MEETING WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF TAIWAN.
THESE ARE GOING TO BE VERY TENSE
AND IMPORTANT FEW HOURS.
SO FOR MORE I BANT TO TALK TO
RETIRED VICE ADMIRAL MURETTE
ALONG WITH ABBY PHILLIP, ANCHOR
OF INSIDE POLITICS SUNDAY.
21 WAR PLANES FROM CHINA INTO
TAIWAN'S AIR DEFENSE ZONE.
STU STAND ON THE COAST YOU MIGHT
BE ABLE TO HEAR THE MILITARY
EXERCISES, SOME WITH LIVE FIRE
AROUND TAIWAN.
THE AMBASSADOR FROM THE U.S. HAS
BEEN SUMMONED BY THE CHINESE
COUNTERPART.
THERE'S BEEN CYBER ATTACK.
HERE WE ARE IN THE NEXT FEW
HOURS, WILL THIS ESCALATE
FURTHER AS PELOSI GOES TO THESE
MEETINGS?
>> THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
I WOULD HOPE NOT.
I WOULD HOPE THIS WOULD BE A
MEASURED RESPONSE FROM CHINA,
WHICH WE EXPECTED, BASED ON
SPEAKER PELOSI'S VISIT BUT THAT
COOLER HEADS WOULD PREVAIL AND
THERE WOULD BE SOME EXERCISE OR
ACTIVITY THAT WILL TAKE PLACE
FOR THE NEXT FEW DAYS OR SO.
AND THE CYBER INTRUSIONS THAT
YOU MENTIONED ALREADY.
IT WOULD BE LIMBED IN SCOPE AND
A MEASURED RESPONSE TO WHAT IS
HAPPENING THERE.
LARGELY FOR DOMESTIC
CONSUMPTION.
I DON'T THINK WE WANT TO UNDER
ESTIMATE SO MUCH THIS HAVE IS
FOR THE CHINESE PUBLIC AND
ESPECIALLY THE SENIOR GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS BECAUSE PRESIDENT XI
IS COMING UP THIS FALL.
>> THE IMAGES OF THE FIGHTER
JETS, THE LIVE FIRE.
THAT IS WHAT THEY'RE PLAYING
AGAIN AND AGAIN ON STATE
TELEVISION.
>> ABBY.
BEFORE SPEAKER PELOSI WENT, THE
PRESIDENT SAID HE DIDN'T THINK
IT WAS A GOOD IDEA.
THE ADMINISTRATION TRIED TO
CONVINCE HER NOT TO GO AND YET
WHAT WE UNDERSTAND IS U.S.
OFFICIALS THINK THAT CHINESE
OFFICIALS DON'T SEE THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN PELOSI AND
BIDEN AND THEY VIEW THIS AS AN
OFFICIAL STATE DIVISION.
>> PELOSI AND BIDEN ARE IN THE
SAME PARTY.
SHE IS IN THE PRESIDENTIAL LINE
OF SUCCESSION WHICH IS WHY, BY
THE WAY, HER VISIT TO TAIWAN
REQUIRES A ROBUST MILITARY
REINFORCEMENT ON THE GROUND.
BUT FROM BIDEN'S PERSPECTIVE,
THERE ARE TWO FACTORS, DOMESTIC
AND INTERNATIONAL.
ON THE DOMESTIC FRONT,
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN ATTACKING
BIDEN ON BEING SOFT ON CHINA.
3W50ID DEN WANTS TO BE TOUGH ON
CHINA, IS TOUGH ON CHINA.
HE BELIEVES THE UNITED STATES
NEEDS TO BE OR ENTED MORE.
HIS OWN PERSONAL VIEW IS TO PUSH
BACK ON CHINA.
THAT IS IN CONFLICT WITH WHAT IS
GOING ON ON THE INTERNATIONAL
SCENE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES IT'S IMPERATIVE TO TAKE
DOWN THE RHETORIC AND TAKE DOWN
THE ANTAGONISM BETWEEN THE TWO
PARTIES.
IT CANNOT BE SEEN JUST ASLETTING
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
DETERMINE WHAT THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE DOES.
>> AND SHE MADE IT CLEAR BY
MAKING IT PUBLIC SHE WAS GOING
TO GO, RIGHT?
SHE TOOK ANY CARDS OUT OF HIS
HANDS.
>> RIGHT.
AND THEN POSSIBLY LOOKING WEAK.
ADMIRAL, CHINA'S MINISTRY OF
DEFENSE, AND THIS IS THEIR
QUOTE, KNOWINGLY AND MALICIOUSLY
PROVOKED AN ISSUE IN CHINA.
I WANT TO LOOK AT THE WORDS.
THE USE OF THE WORDS CRISIS.
IS THIS NOW A CRISIS, ADMIRAL?
>> ERIN, I'D LIKE TO THINK IT'S
NOT.
THAT CAME FROM THE MINISTER OF
DEFENSE, NOT THE FOREIGN
MINISTER OR PRESIDENT XI.
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
YOU WOULD EXPECT TO HAVE COME
FROM A DEFENSE MINISTER WHICH IS
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT YOU MIGHT
HEAR FROM SOMEBODY ELSE IN
GOVERNMENT.
I'M HOPEFUL HERE SETTLE DOWN IN
SHORT ORDER AS IMPORTANTLY
SPEAKER PELOSI GOES INTO THESE
OTHER COUNTRIES.
>> I WOULD IMAGINE THEY'RE GOING
TO DO THESE MEETINGS AND THEY
LEAVE.
SOME OF THE DEMOCRATIC CRITICISM
HAS COME IN STARK CONTRAST
267892 SENATE REPUBLICANS SAY
THEY'RE FULLY COMMITTED TO
TAIWAN.
HERE IS ONE OF THEM.
>> I'M ABOUT TO USE FOUR WORDS
IN A ROW THAT I HAVEN'T USED IN
THIS WAY BEFORE AND THOSE FOUR
WORDS ARE SPEAKER PELOSI WAS
RIGHT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
NO DOUBT MANY OF THEM COMPLETELY
BELIEVE WHAT THEY'RE SAYING.
THEY'RE GLAD SHE'S GOING, THIS
IS TRUE, BUT THEY'RE ALSO, YOU
KNOW, PUTTING OUT A LETTER AND
ALL OF THAT.
THERE'S POLITICALLY A GAMES
MANSHIP GOING ON.
>> IT HELPS FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE PELOSI IS
APPARENTLY, YOU KNOW, SORT OF
PUSHING BACK ON BIDEN.
>> SOMETHING --
>> PUSHING BACK ON BIDEN.
SOMETHING REPUBLICANS ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF.
LET'S BE HONEST HERE, THE
REPUBLICAN POSITION, THEY ARE
TOUGH ON CHINA, DEMOCRATS ARE
NOT, IS A LARGELY POLITICAL
CONSTRUCTION.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
PERSONALLY, WAS VERY FRIENDLY.
TRUMP HIMSELF, HE LOVED WHEN XI
JINPING ROLLED OUT THE RED
CARPET FOR HIM ON HIS VACATION.
A LOT OF THIS IS MITT TERM BUT
AS YOU CAN SEE HER